quand le patrimoine se met à l'art le
temps d'un week-end le Potager du Roi de
Versailles s'est transformé en atelier à
ciel ouvert un moyen de découvrir le
patrimoine culturel et naturel de la
région donc
à l'occasion de la 7e édition estivale
déjà ouvert le célèbre jardin versaillé
à ouvert ses portes aux artistes dont
l'intérêt est double c'est de faire
découvrir le jardin d'une autre manière
effectivement
et d'interroger aussi pour pour les
visiteur ce dialogue alors ici entre
l'art et le jardin sculpteur ou encore
artiste plasticien ont répondu à l'appel
pour présenter leurs œuvres dans un
cadre exceptionnel auquel il faut
s'adapter il a eu la chance de
rencontrer le chef jardinier ici on lui
a posé pas mal de questions sur ces
alignements c'est ça qui nous a inspiré
d'essayer de créer une forme qui
jaillissent finalement de cette
alignement parfait magnifique et donc on
a créé cette oeuvre qui est une force
d'eau de la nature du vivant une
explosion en fait de bissonnante une
cohérence entre l'art et la nature que
les artistes exploitent et qui les
inspirent je propose aux participants de
réaliser des des plaques collectives
chacun vient graver à son tour dans une
plaque de bois un motif un élément de
branchage qui va grandir au fur et à
mesure et l'ouverture de ces jardins
estivaux à attirer les curieux comme ce
père et sa fille venu un peu par hasard
on laisse libre cours à son imagination
parce que quand même très intéressant on
peut travailler la matière les couleurs
on découvre des nouvelles techniques et
puis on travaille en famille à tout le
monde qu'on soit adulte sur mon avis
même enfant de réaliser quelque chose de
la fois créatif et
il est facile et si vous aussi vous
souhaitez vous essayez à des ateliers
artistiques tout en profitant de la
beauté du patrimoine local vous avez
jusqu'au 27 août pour profiter des
jardins ouverts dans le département